il a eu sa revanche il n'aura fallu que
deux heures et 18 minutes à rafael nadal
pour battre robin soderling en finale de
roland garros l'espagnol voulait prendre
sa revanche depuis que le suédois
l'avait sorti l'année dernière en
huitièmes de finale julien benedetto
guillaume michel la coupe des
mousquetaires retrouve son maître plus
fort que jamais rafael nadal émue aux
larmes remporte à seulement 24 ans son
cinquième roland-garros il récupère le
trône de numéro un mondial devant la
reine sofia d'espagne
joan ramon mais le sibac au paletot de
la supporte mentionnant de la vergne
encadré merci beaucoup
le suspense aura duré un set
indébordable nadal a écoeuré robin
soderling défense acharnée couverture de
terrain exceptionnelle le taureau de
majorque a réduit à l'impuissance le
colosse scandinave
une démonstration qui sonne comme une
éclatante revanche
soderling avait battu nadal ici-même
l'an dernier 6 4 6 2 6 4
comme en 2008 l'espagnol gagne le
tournoi sans perdre un set
il est désormais tout près du record de
borg six fois vainqueur porte d'auteuil
nadal partage son triomphe avec la reine
d'espagne avant de retrouver ses proches
dans l'intimité des vestiaires le patron
de roland garros est de retour